Hi everybody.
Thank you for being here with me today.
I'm so pleased to be here and have a chance to introduce our guest speaker
today.
May Ms. Lee,
she's uh,
the father of runners.
She has to be in one of the proponents of this program for the kids and she also
just a fascinating person and please join me
in welcoming Mary viscerally.
Thank you.
Hi everybody.
Alright,
so,
um,
let's see.
Oh,
what am I got talking about today?
So,
um,
first of all,
number one is it's really good to see you and I think the food here is the best
I've ever seen in a corporate cafeteria.
It's just fantastic and thank you for all the excess who that you give food
runners.
We are picking up masses of food every day and taking it directly to the
shelters where it is either serve that night or chilled and serve the next day.
So it really,
really means a lot to the shelters in San Francisco.
Um,
what's the story about Mary Risley?
Mary Risley was a,
a young woman who drove across the Trans Canada highway and a blue Mustang 50
years ago.
And came down to San Francisco in the summer of love when everybody was sharing,
they were sharing sex,
apartments,
marijuana.
And uh,
it was a major influence to me,
the the summer of love.
And um,
and uh,
uh,
by the way,
I still have the Blue Mustang.
And um,
that was 50 years ago.
I tried,
uh,
for five years to be a secretary and were patty hose and golf and,
and apart and go up on a bus and a corporate office and,
and tried to get the men to think they want to marry me and none of it worked.
And so after five years,
I said,
fuck this.
And somebody said,
what have you always wanted to do?
And I said,
I've always wanted to be a cooking teacher.
So I started teaching cooking in a ratty Leavenworth Street apartment.
I hand wrote the recipes.
I walked down to a bank at California and Montgomery,
somebody copied them on a xerox machine for free.
And I went home and taught everybody what I'd learned in mastering the art of
French cooking by Julia Child.
So I'm a big fraud.
That was in 1973 and 1979 I started a fulltime culinary school,
Tom Murray's.
And if you Google Mary Grisly,
um,
you will see my video.
How many people have already done that?
Uh,
the video I made five years ago,
which is timely now is,
uh,
just put the fucking Turkey in an oven,
have a glass of wine,
take a walk and don't worry about it.
Thank you.
Youtube.
Thank you Google.
So,
um,
if you go to food,
if you go to [inaudible] dot com my,
my,
uh,
website,
um,
you will see there are 350 recipes on how to cook and 32 youtube videos on how
to cook.
And of course now I'm out of date because people are putting videos on other
things and,
and things like that.
But,
um,
uh,
I'm a very lucky girl that I've been able to support myself as a cooking teacher
for the last 45 years.
The next thing I am I,
okay.
And then the picture up there,
do I look okay?
Yes.
I look skinny and beautiful.
Um,
the,
uh,
what is food runners?
Food runners was started in 1987 with me and a group of women.
And,
uh,
what,
what we do is we provide any business in San Francisco with the free service,
High Free Service of picking their leftover up,
picking up their leftover perishable and prepared foods and taking it to the
shelters,
taking it to the,
what I call the shelters.
It's really the neighborhood feeding programs.
And so what happens is,
um,
uh,
we have currently 200 volunteers in their own car,
one paid truck driver,
a man running around in a van,
his own van who's paid and two bike couriers.
And what those people are doing is picking up leftover perishable and prepared
foods and taking it right from the donor to the person,
uh,
to the people that they're going to serve it that night for dinner.
The,
we do have a slide show to go with a,
a PowerPoint presentation.
And so,
um,
if,
if we have it up,
we could,
uh,
we could talk a little bit about,
my pp.
It's called a PPP.
I understand a PowerPoint presentation,
no idea how to use something like that myself.
Um,
so,
uh,
so what happened?
I talked about a little bit earlier,
I talked about my coming to San Francisco 50 years in the summer of love.
And that was a time when we were all,
uh,
when people were sharing it was a,
it was also time when it was cheap to live San Francisco,
but if you could believe the hat.
And,
uh,
so what we do is we provide,
businesses in San Francisco with this free service of picking up their leftover
food.
And,
um,
so what you might have heard of the San Francisco Food Bank.
The food bank is a huge building down in Indiana street,
which is a warehouse of non perishable foods.
So people that are,
um,
people that are,
uh,
that,
like Kellogg's and Delmonte,
uh,
he can donate,
um,
you know,
green beans that have the wrong label on them or,
or,
or cereals or stuff like that.
So there are,
we,
food runners takes to over 300 different neighborhood feeding programs,
but those programs can go to the San Francisco Food Bank and buy food.
Um,
you know,
like in a shopping cart for 18 cents a pound,
it's donated food.
The 18 cents goes to pay for,
you know,
the,
uh,
operating costs.
But what do you,
what do you do with the trays of lentils with mushrooms at trays of,
uh,
of noodles with pork that,
um,
that,
that can't go to a big warehouse down on Indiana Street?
So that's why food runners started 30 years ago to supplement what the food bank
can't do.
And,
uh,
currently we're,
so this is,
uh,
so we could,
we could,
uh,
currently we're delivering food,
um,
directly to places around town.
As I said earlier,
that can be,
um,
that can serve it that night or the next day.
So,
um,
what is food waste?
Food waste is a,
um,
it,
no,
let's go back to that previous one.
Let's go back to the previous,
uh,
who's doing that?
Who's clicking?
You are?
Oh,
Shit.
So wait a minute.
I saw John Stewart last night.
He was hiding behind something like this.
Wait,
I can do it.
Let me do it.
Show me how to do it.
Yes.
Oh yeah.
I can't do it.
Okay,
here we go.
I want to do one.
And then the other.
Okay.
So,
um,
so look at this.
40% of the,
so,
uh,
these,
this is the statistics.
So the estimate a 40% of the food and the country is discarded and um,
20% of the food that is bought and taken home is discarded.
And,
um,
and as you know,
uh,
one the,
there are so very,
very many people that are going to bed hungry.
And I,
one of the big problems in this con in the city,
I think is that you have,
if people have an apartment and,
and a two or three kids,
I mean,
they can usually pay rent,
but they don't have enough for food.
So there's a lot of hungry people.
You've seen it,
all that,
have you seen it all down here?
Right?
You see it all the time.
So,
um,
when we're talking about,
rescuing a perishable and prepared foods,
um,
the first thing that comes to everybody's mind is,
oh,
no,
first when you go into a store or go into a business,
do you ever throw food away?
They say,
oh,
no,
we never throw food away.
Well,
here's our card,
here's the phone number,
here's our,
uh,
website.
And uh,
and then they will say,
oh,
it's not the company policy.
Well,
who do I talk to to change the policy?
Okay.
And then we're worried about liability.
Well,
the bottom line is it in San Fran,
in the country,
in the United States,
nobody has ever sued after receiving donated food.
There is.
And the,
and the donor has been protected by laws since the 80s in California.
And the Good Samaritan,
what's commonly called the Good Samaritan Act in the night nineties by that Bill
Clinton sign.
So there is no need.
There's no need to,
um,
okay,
here I'm going to try it.
Do,
do to do,
didn't work.
So there's no need to fear liability.
And so list of,
of this,
uh,
so where does food,
renters pickup food?
We've been picking up at whole foods at Franklin and California ever since they
started.
We pick up at every trader Joe's in the city,
every trader Joe's in the city.
Um,
listen to trader Joe's doesn't want a publicity about it.
They just do it out of the goodness of their heart and they give us milk.
Next one please.
They give us milk,
uh,
meet,
dairy flowers that have all gone by their expiration date.
Expiration dates doesn't mean a fucking thing.
What happens is it is something that was created by it.
It's,
it's a Ma,
it's at the manufacturer's discretion to put on the expiration date,
you know,
by,
by expires after blah,
blah,
blah.
No nothing.
There's nothing.
I myself have kept a uh,
chicken,
a cooked chicken and eating it three weeks after I roasted it.
I see a cook,
I've cooked with eggs six weeks after I bought them.
And you know,
I've got cream in my fridge that has an expiration date of injury of October 26.
I opened it up,
smell it and use it,
you know,
you know that,
I mean we all that it's a,
don't throw it out until it starts to smell.
When I was a cooking school in France and 150 years ago,
the,
the chefs used to break the egg and open it up and smell it to see if it was
bad.
Can you imagine that?
We don't get bad eggs,
so we're what's,
where does food waste come from?
Where does food waste come from?
The bottom line is,
the first place that it comes from is,
um,
the,
the farmer doesn't want to pay to have somebody go through and pick the
strawberries again.
So if the strawberries are,
the peppers weren't ripe when he hires the migrant workers,
he,
he doesn't,
he doesn't want to pay to have somebody go back and get it again.
So that,
so nowadays there's groups called gleaners that are trying to go and get the,
get the produce from the farms after the pickers have gone through.
The next thing that happens as you know,
is that the guys sorting the apples at the,
at the,
at the distribution center is,
is this one,
he can sell this when he can't.
This is when he can sell this,
when he can.
So the ones that he can't sell,
we used to be discarded.
It wasn't,
it wasn't worth his while to,
uh,
but now there's a group here that's,
that's uh,
we'll go and get what they call imperfect food.
So that's a good one.
The,
um,
the huge place for sources food that we just talked about is grocery stores and,
uh,
also whenever,
so they're all,
so as we pick up at whole foods,
trader Joe's Gusset,
we pick up all over town,
uh,
the food that,
the grocery guy doesn't want to put out and,
or the,
or the food that,
um,
are the food that doesn't sell and is a little too old.
So,
uh,
that's what food runners for.
And then another big thing is,
as you know,
we just talked about 20% of the food taken home is discarded.
And I have to say the other day I threw out five carrots that have been in the,
in the bottom of my fridge for ever.
They were just pretty bad looking wilted carrots.
Uh,
they actually looked like something that,
um,
Dominique Crenn would cook.
She likes it.
She likes the roast carrots for 54 hours or so many.
Uh,
but anyway,
the reason I put my website up there,
the Fr Murray website is there.
There are,
as I said,
there are 350 recipes on there.
And you know what?
So there we have a group of young,
I say that,
uh,
in order to get young enrich,
you have to have blonde hair and San Francisco.
And then you have to have drive a SUV,
land rover or BMW or a Porsche poor Alfa Romeos coming out with an Siv SUV for,
and then you have to have blonde dogs and blonde kids.
But those blondes afraid of leftovers.
So they,
they go and they buy their meal and then they throw the leftovers away.
You don't have to row leftovers away.
You could,
you could it turn,
you could turn your leftovers from uh,
uh,
leftover spaghetti,
and,
and you can keep it in the fridge for up to a week.
And if it doesn't have meat juices in it and,
uh,
you can spread it out in a pan,
a buttered pan and beat up some eggs and throw it in and make a Frittata out of
leftover spaghetti,
you can make it into something else.
He said,
that's what good cooks.
Don't know.
Gus.
What people don't know is that they say,
oh,
we don't like leftovers but good cooks know that you can take leftovers and turn
it into something else.
What is salad?
Niece was leftover green beans,
leftover potatoes,
the throw a can of tuna fish.
Ah,
am I right?
So anyway,
um,
the uh,
so what,
what the sources of food waste are,
are,
are the farm,
the distribution center,
the grocery store and the home.
And,
uh,
so,
so if we can try and pick up at those places and teach people how to reuse their
leftovers and not by too much that they don't need and don't worry about
expiration dates,
then we can help to avoid food waste.
What can we do about people here?
So I'm a 70 fucking six years old and I'm at the age where if I go to a
restaurant,
I don't eat all the food.
So what's happening from my generation is a lot of people will eat half the,
their portion of chicken or fish or whatever it is,
and then ask for a little box to take the rest home in and then they eat,
then eat it cold for lunch the next day.
That's what older women do.
Um,
but w,
uh,
how can you teach Googlers not to take so much on their plate and then,
and then they,
they think,
oh,
well it's being composted.
Well,
it's still,
you don't need to take so much food if you're not going to eat it.
And so that,
that's,
uh,
how you teach people not to do that.
I don't know.
Um,
you,
you tell them about the 76 year old lady that has a little box,
um,
to take home and eat it cold the next day.
But,
um,
the next,
okay.
Next.
Um,
so,
uh,
what,
you know is that what we all know is that if I take a plate of,
um,
today I had delicious lentils and,
and uh,
uh,
noodles here for lunch.
If I,
if I take too much food on my plate,
I can it in a little box and take it home.
But the food that was all out on the buffet that is not reusable,
uh,
for another day,
all can be packaged and donated.
And,
um,
so,
uh,
that's uh,
that's why we are,
uh,
oh,
we have so much tins of food from businesses like yours that we pick up and take
to the shelters.
Um,
so what I thought I'd,
this is a list of the five places that your food is donated to five days a week.
So,
um,
you don't have to hang out there.
Come on,
stand up,
come on,
stand up.
And [inaudible] were the Christmas girls green and red.
So,
um,
the,
the last place that the place Derek Silva,
it's a 68 units of affordable housing.
It is for people living with HIV AIDS.
And so,
so the,
the food that your,
the Google is donating to through food runners every day has been taking to
those five places.
A,
uh,
agency serving a hot meal to anybody that comes to the door,
a mental health treatment program for a ex cons,
a church for the,
uh,
serving meals to the homeless,
cannon,
Kipp as an elderly and Derek silver's HIV.
So those people are totally spoiled by your food.
And could we take more from Google?
The answer is yes.
We can take the yogurt that's over there.
We can take the,
the uh,
fruit that's in the cafes.
We can take everything that has not been served on a plate to somebody sitting
there spitting on it and putting their fingers in it.
Okay.
So,
so be sure,
uh,
for instance,
those Po,
I'll take those pumpkin's when I leave,
I'll put those,
I'll put those in my purse.
All buffet food is donated will where we pick up at the Hilton.
Uh,
today we're picking up at the Ritz Carlton today from the Ritz Carlton.
It's taken,
it's taken from the Ritz Carlton is taken about a,
uh,
nine months were first we got there leftover banquet food and now we're getting
the leftover food from the takeout places.
But it's just amazing the misinformation that people have.
I heard once about somebody,
it was actually bone appetit and bon appetit company and down in the peninsula
bone appetit is the food provider.
And they,
and they throw out the,
they put out yogurt in an ice bath and when the ice melts,
they throw the yogurt out.
I mean,
that's ridiculous.
Yogurt is bacteria.
Yogurt keeps running,
so no food needs to be thrown away.
You can donate it.
It this,
put it in the package and call food runners.
Um,
so can I have the next to the next one's probably a photo.
So what is food waste?
Food waste.
It has many sources and,
but I think it's kind of uneducated people that don't know that they,
they,
uh,
or,
or it's people that don't care one more,
um,
and,
or they're in,
they're in the habit of throwing food away,
you know,
the,
the people.
Uh,
so it takes a long time too.
Um,
it takes a long time to get people to change their habits.
And I'm,
so the habits are,
uh,
eight only what you take only what you think you can eat,
save the rest for,
um,
uh,
to donate and,
um,
uh,
see that a responsible organization like food runners picks it up and takes it
where it can best be used.
The next thing that,
um,
I was going to that I think that you,
what you can help food runners with is,
first of all,
maybe we could pass these out to everybody and pass these out to everybody.
So the,
the deal is that because I'm an old secretary,
I,
uh,
do things with cards and brochures and,
but hold onto these.
And so we're still kind of in the process at food runners were kind of in the
process.
That's Canadian for process.
We're kind of in the process of,
uh,
trying to get more into the new technology.
For instance,
we are,
um,
uh,
we are,
working on an app where P uh,
but currently people can donate through the website or the APP.
Uh,
we still have a phone with an answering service so people can call and leave a
message on an answering service.
I mean an answer,
uh,
answering a voicemail.
But,
um,
what,
what I think you,
how you can help as Googlers,
as San Franciscans and as concerned people is tell,
tell first of all,
tell your friends,
uh,
the best,
the best.
Don't uh,
volunteers.
For us,
we had our people who are in between jobs,
people who were in between jobs.
That's fine.
People are in between jobs or recently retired.
Make really good volunteers because they're used to getting up and going
somewhere.
So if you know anybody that's recently retired or,
um,
or between jobs,
tell them that this is,
and they have their own vehicle,
this is a really good place to,
to volunteers with food runners.
Um,
we also could use help through social media,
um,
by letting,
by letting people,
by taking pictures of the food you're donating and,
and,
and to saying,
this is going to food,
this is going to neighborhood shelters through food runners.
So we can,
we can,
we could use to help with social media.
We can use help with,
um,
telling everybody,
you know,
with food we can use.
Um,
and what else can we use help with?
We,
um,
uh,
if you know anybody with a car for one.
Uh,
so I want to tell you a little bit more about some of the people that are
volunteers for us.
There's a man who came here,
actually,
I shouldn't say this,
but he came here also came here in the 50s and earned his living as a drug
dealer.
And then he went into the,
um,
uh,
waterproofing and painting business.
And this guy is,
um,
has been picking up at the ferry plaza farmer's market,
all the leftover food from the farmers.
Um,
every Saturday whenever he's in San Francisco.
And he could walk though,
you'll see his,
he goes and gets the truck.
We use a truck for large donations,
it goes and gets the truck and he's,
he's a Brit so you can see him at one 30,
1231 o'clock in the,
at the ferry building going food runners,
food runners,
bring out your food.
So it takes him four hours every day to deliver all the food that the farmers
bring him because he has a relationship with them and they,
the farmers at the ferry and then the farmers at the ferry bill bring him all,
even extra food on Saturdays.
There is a nother guy kind of who I would call a trust fund baby.
He's at,
uh,
well,
well to do man who lives out on Washington street in Pacific heights and he has
a 17 year old daughter and he and his daughter go on food runs every Saturday.
They,
uh,
the US,
Sunday.
Every Sunday.
He goes,
he does Saturday at carers,
cupcakes on Steiner Street,
no Scott Street.
And he takes a,
takes bread and pastries out to the veterans home out on,
uh,
on Presidio.
And then,
um,
on,
on Saturday,
on Sunday,
he goes to the farmer's market at Fort Mason and picks up all their leftover
foods and takes it to a place called Walden House on with what I call Walden
House on Hayes and Fillmore.
And,
um,
so,
uh,
so what it,
and then there's a guy called Sam Haskins,
Sam Haskins.
Uh,
we'll go today at about three 30 to a restaurant called Cook Cari who makes a
foil trays of food for him.
And,
uh,
he's a retired,
um,
he's a lawyer who writes books.
Um,
we also have women doing deliveries too.
We have,
um,
but they're there.
So they're of the volunteers for food runners and some of them have been
volunteers for 30 years.
They,
uh,
some people like to know that they're going to go every Friday at four o'clock
in the afternoon to pick up the leftover food at the William Sonoma corporate
office.
And,
and some people like to know that,
that they're going to go to,
oh,
there's a brand new place,
I don't know if you've been to it,
it's called Breck Makati Makati.
It's a,
a society deli on post between Larkin and hide that just opened two weeks ago,
a guy called Stanley Gaddy was,
is the owner and he brought in the New York a bunch of New York hot shots and
they,
they put all this Kabuto and Sauerkraut and tea,
uh,
Chia seeds and all is trendy food in there.
And,
um,
and so they have,
and you go,
what,
what are they doing on post between Larkin and hide?
It's kind of like renters,
you know,
neighborhood.
But they've got all the society people coming in their limos and,
and they send their chauffeurs the pickup food.
But um,
that,
that New Delhi on Post Street is giving up all their leftover food every,
every.
I went and picked that myself every night at nine o'clock.
The first week they were open and now they save the food and the cooler.
And we picked up the next day.
But have you been there?
No,
I was just thinking of,
it might be
spot that's on southern.
This is a post.
It's a kind of crappy building.
Yeah.
So I got to tell more jokes or he got a phone call.
Huh.
So,
so anyway,
so,
so we,
we're,
we pick up at bakeries,
grocery stores,
um,
Deli's like this place,
uh,
Molly stones.
So listen to this.
So I am,
uh,
in Molly stones all the time because,
on California and Franklin,
and it's taken me 10 years to get the Molly stones to donate their leftover
food.
And,
um,
and the,
and what changed their mind was I named my dog Molly stone.
I got a new dog last year and called it Molly stone.
But,
you know,
it's,
it's hard to convince people that,
as I said,
to change their habits.
But we have w we have 200 volunteers in their own,
uh,
one,
we were picking up five o 500 times a week with a van,
a truck,
and our volunteers with regular runs.
And then,
uh,
other people that are on calls,
some people just like to be on call,
getting their car and go.
And,
uh,
we also pick up,
I said,
I talked about the Ritz Carlton and,
um,
the Hilton,
we also pick up from caterers.
Uh,
there's a big cater,
a called Dan Mccall who has a commissary kitchen on 17th street.
He will take back his leftover food to the commissary kitchen,
will come the next day and pick it up.
Um,
there is another caterer called Paula Duke out of Emeryville.
She will,
uh,
so she doesn't take it back to Emeryville.
She calls us and we pick it up at one 30 at night.
And,
uh,
so somebody suggested recently that maybe we should have Uber drivers,
we should have Uber because of their bad reputation,
uh,
sponsor,
cars going around and picking up food for us.
Um,
and you go,
ah,
I don't know,
cause they might get,
they might get a cream chicken all over the back of their car.
So anyway,
um,
the regular people,
we have 500 people,
uh,
no,
150 people.
A truck driver,
a van,
and a couple of cargo bikes going around and picking up food either as regular
runners or volunteers.
And I still need that last thing about the call to action,
the call to action.
Uh,
what can you do to help?
You can help us with social media.
You can help us with spreading the word to food businesses.
You can help us with,
uh,
letting anybody who might want to be a volunteer.
No.
And then the fourth way,
I,
I can't remember.
So we'll have to get back to that.
Uh,
we'll get back to spread the word,
tell your friends and uh,
and get and help us get more food to those in need in San Francisco.
Before I open it up for questions,
I want to tell you a little bit more about the,
uh,
well,
this place that I like to take food to Wa oh yes.
Listen to this.
So the other day I got,
uh,
somebody,
somebody donated three garbage bags full of these,
uh,
paper containers that you might take soup Homan and so I took him to a Walden
House,
but I want to tell you about Walden House.
Walden house is a now called healthright three 60 and it's a,
they recruit men and women coming out of jail who've had repeated,
you know,
who,
who have keep going back to being,
having drugs and getting into trouble.
And uh,
they,
they housed them for six months.
And so it's a rehab center.
They have eight locations in San Francisco.
And what has happened is that because of the food we eat,
the cause of the food that we bring them from people like you,
um,
that has saved them $2 million a year that they would otherwise have to spend
on,
on by making food for them.
So thank you Google for all your food.
Thank you for Youtube.
Where I got my fame.
And what kind of questions do you have for me about food rescue,
food waste and food runners?
Actually,
I got two questions from Kevin.
First year.
So he has two questions for you.
So,
um,
what policies should we be trying to pass the lower barriers to sharing food and
what policies?
Yes.
Should we pass?
To low to lower barriers to sharing food.
There are no policies.
Just pick up the fucking food.
Okay.
The second one,
should we,
should we more actively pushed people to be rigid to giving that covet?
So should we push people to be vegetarians?
Um,
I don't think that has anything to do with rescuing food.
Uh,
I mean we do listen to this in San Francisco.
There are,
uh,
but it's well known that the,
the homeless people are the pickiest eaters.
So if you were to go serve food at glide or say to Anthony or Martin de Porres,
you do have people going through the line saying,
does that have sugar in it?
Does that have gluten?
So there are,
there are,
uh,
even in Sanford,
even the homeless,
the hungry are,
are picky eaters here,
but I think vegetarianism is a personal choice.
Yes,
sweetheart.
Hello.
Testing.
Um,
I would just curious like what
inspired the inspiration for the initial,
do you hear you were,
you were running a cookie school,
um,
and then you decided to start this food runner sometime later.
You said 1987.
What was the,
what was happening at that moment?
What did you see?
What,
what did what
quite frankly,
I used to,
um,
stop in my red Alpha male at the corner of,
uh,
every day I crossed the corner of chestnut and Columbus.
And you see people going through the garbage looking for food.
And,
um,
so I,
what I did,
I had an n w at one time that my cooking school,
we did a two day wedding cake workshop.
And I,
so at the end of the two days I had,
we,
we cut into them,
we taste it,
but I had seven wedding cakes.
Do I drive them to glide?
Do I,
um,
give them to the staff or do I,
do I throw them in the garbage?
And so I thought,
well,
there must be other people in the food business that have that same question.
And the truth is,
I still have that too.
And um,
I still have buttercream all over the steering wheel because I drove it to
glide.
I drove those wedding cakes to glide in 1986.
I approached the,
the mayor's office,
Diane Feinstein was the mayor then and said,
I have food connections.
Can,
can I,
can we help?
And she introduced me to a woman in Berkeley who was kind of a whole,
whole,
um,
mother earth time of woman.
And she taught me how to do this.
Uh,
and so we started with a small group of people,
food runners saying,
we're going to provide this free service to any business in San Francisco.
And what do we do?
If,
so,
what do you do if you have a party in your home?
And then not everybody comes.
And,
uh,
so what you can do,
what you can do as a home cook is packaged to the food and,
and you can look on food runners.org the a website and it'll tell you where your
neighborhood place that you can take food too.
If you live in north beach,
you can take it to north beach citizens.
If you live in out my,
the,
you know,
there's a place called Edgewood out by the zoo,
things like that.
So we can't pick up in homes but,
but home food can be taken and um,
and there are,
I have a oh,
okay.
What it's that answer your question.
Yes.
And one more quick question.
Have you seen that documentary wasted and what do you think of Anthony fucking
board?
Dan?
Uh,
I haven't seen the documentary.
They asked me if I would be in it and he,
uh,
he's a definitely a newcomer to the whole thing,
you know.
Have you seen the documentary?
Was it any good?
It was actually pretty good.
Yeah,
I bet.
So Tony Bourdain,
as you know,
as made his reputation as a bad boy,
throwing cigarette butts and melted butter and restaurants where he worked in
grand central station.
But he's,
he has great writers and great producers and so,
so if they're helping the food movement,
God bless them.
Yeah.
Hello?
Hi.
Hello.
I was introduced to your company about 10 years ago,
working in grocery,
working on whole foods,
you know,
and so it was a very interesting moment of just like the idea of food waste and
how it's being acknowledged.
And it seems like perhaps like you guys could have been like a kind of like
setting an industry standard for a sledge.
And I'm curious if like other cities or other cities.
Yeah,
so what happens is there is now a,
uh,
a,
kind of a food,
food waste.
Uh,
I mean the food recovery group in Sonoma county that I trained,
there's one in Marin county that I helped train.
There's one in the peninsula I help train.
There's one in Wilksbear,
Pennsylvania that I helped work with,
this one in northwest Connecticut.
So,
um,
and there's a great one in Toronto that I didn't have anything to do with,
but,
um,
uh,
food waste is becoming a huge topic.
And,
uh,
I even saw it on the,
a side of a moving van.
I can't remember the name of the moving company,
but it had a big sign on it saying move,
move for hunger.org and it appears at the moving company,
this getting all your uh,
furniture and taking it to somewhere.
We'll also take all your food from your cupboards and donated.
So food waste is becoming a really good topic and it's great that,
uh,
everybody's becoming involved in it.
Okay.
Any other questions?
So the other thing that I'm going to finish with is,
um,
uh,
I know that you all are,
most of you are trained professionals in food and um,
I want to,
I want to tell you a story about,
so w w w we had a truck donated to us 20 years ago from ups and it was a
refrigerated truck.
And so I went to a party and that the middle of the night put my,
um,
all the donated food in it took it to,
it was being part,
it was,
um,
we used a parking space at Royal Hawaiian seafood and,
and plugged it in.
I plugged in,
but it turned the next day I went back to get the truck to deliver the food to
the shelters.
And,
um,
uh,
and,
and the,
it was clear that the refrigeration didn't work.
And so what,
so I had big bags of carrots and celery bread and,
uh,
bags of chuck cooked chicken and I,
and so what I did was I took the,
I drove the truck to fifth and Bryant to the shelter at fifth and Bryant and I a
w taking the bags of bread inside,
taking the carrots inside.
And I,
and I tried to put the chicken into the dumpster and the homeless guys started
that were waiting to get in the shelter,
started climbing in the dumpster,
and Paul and I'm like,
oh,
no,
you can make you sick.
And they go,
lady,
we're hungry.
You know,
the it,
there's,
there's no need to fear liability.
And we,
I don't care what the health department says in San Francisco or Wilkes Barre,
Pennsylvania or a Truckee,
California,
it's [inaudible].
If you let the health department,
I mean,
of course you have to obey their rules when you're in the food business,
but,
um,
they will try and tell you,
oh,
it has to be chilled at this temperature and rain and take the 10 fucking
temperature.
No,
it's food and they're hungry people there.
They're not going to follow you out the door to find out where the s the salad
is going.
I just,
you know,
uh,
I'm an old hippie from the,
from the 60s.
Um,
it,
eh,
we can't,
uh,
W W W we can't be run by rules and regulations when they're hungry people.
And we have to,
as civilized human beings,
we have to take care of our fellow human beings.
As far as I know,
we're the only animal in the world that,
that cook that he heats food and makes it a taste good.
And,
um,
uh,
you know,
we,
we don't,
we aren't like deer or raccoons gone around the Presidio picking up food and,
and,
uh,
and as,
as far as ad,
and we have to take care of our fellow human beings and,
and with one out of every four people going to bed hungry in San Francisco,
we need to do everything we can to help them.
Thank you.